THAT HUGE FOURTH QUARTER RUN.
JUST A FLURRY OF THREES.
MARVELOUS.
>> Marv: KHRIS MIDDLETON, AN
ALL-STAR THE PAST TWO SEASONS.
AVERAGED 20 POINTS SIX REBOUNDS
FIVE ASSISTS DURING THE REGULAR
SEASON.
NINE YEAR MAN OUT OF TEXAS A&M.
LET'S GO TO STEPH AND CHRIS
MIDDLETON.
>> Stephanie: CAREER HIGH FOUR.
DOUBLE DIGIT REBOUNDS, NEARLY
DOUBLE DIGIT ASSISTS.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE FOR YOU ON THE
FLOOR TONIGHT AGAINST THESE
HAWKS?
>> TOUGH.
THEY ARE A GREAT TEAM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DIDN'T SEE THEM
BEING HERE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THE SEASON.
BUT THEY ARE HERE FOR A REASON.
THEY PLAY WELL.
>> Stephanie: WHAT WAS THE
GENESIS OF THOSE RUNS.
WE SAW YOU GO ON A BIG ONE TO
END THE HALF AND TAKE THE LEAD.
>> JUST STAYING WITH IT.
WE JUST STUCK WITH IT.
KEPT TRYING TO DRIND THEM DOWN
AND EVENTUALLY GO ON OUR RUN.
>> Stephanie: SPEAKING OF
HITTING EVERY SHOT YOU DID A
LITTLE BIT OF THAT YOURSELF
TOWARDS THE END OF THE FOURTH
QUARTER?
WERE YOU DOING SOMETHING
DIFFERENT?
WERE YOUR TEAMMATES HELP SETTING
YOU UP?
>> JUST GOT THEM TOGET